[Music]  we're behind the scenes for the Middle's  series finale I think we were kind of at  the top of our game really and you want  I think that's how you want to leave you  don't want people pushing you out you  want to be like okay we're gonna go  instead of by nine seasons 215 episodes  that all comes to an end tonight  there's one thing I will not miss around  here your smelly socks what are we  stealing from set to take home they tag  every other set has a tag they know  where it is there are a handful of  posters in the students room that are  going up in my art room I really want a  kitchen stool but I don't know if I can  take it super vans no Patricia Heaton  'he's character loves to indulge in icy  straight from the tub so in honor of the  beloved family theories Cheers  beer delicious  [Music]